[موسيقى]
وقفتنا الثانيه مع مراسلين مساء العربي
وهذه المره من لندن مع زميلتنا عروب عبد
الحق لتنقل لنا اجواء رمضان كيف بدت لندن
مساء الخير اهلا بك رمضان كريم كيف تبدو
اجواء رمضان في عاصمه
[موسيقى]
رمضان كريم سهام مدينه بالفعل يعني هناك
ساعتين ساعتين ونصف حتى موعد الافطار هنا
في لندن والحقيقه ان اجواء رمضان مختلفه
ربما هذا العام في لندن بسبب لعده اسباب
من هذه الاسباب زينه رمضان كما ترون من
خلف هناك حوالي 30 الف من زينه رمضان من
فوانيس ونجوم والزنا الخاصه برمضان تم
اضاءتها في هذا الشارع هذا الشارع من يعني
اهم الشوارع الذي يربط منطقه
بساحه ليستر وهذه تعد احدى اكثر المناطق
ازدحاما في لندن طبعا هذه المناطق كانت
مخصصه في يعني دائما لاضاءه انوار الاعياد
مشاهد
[موسيقى]
نعم بالفعل يعني وهذه يعني كانت الانوار
تجذب
السياح لرؤيه الانوار في ديسمبر ولكن هذا
العام جذبت العديد من السياح الى هذا يعني
الشارع بالتحديد طبعا هناك من ياتي خصوصا
لهذه الانوار وهناك من ياتي طبعا لانه
هناك يعني صادقت صدقه رمضان يعني احتفالات
اعياد الفصح المجيد ايضا في البلاد طبعا
هي عطله رسميه لمده اربعه ايام وبالتالي
هناك توافق كبير الى الى هذا الشارع طبعا
هناك مليون و300 الف مسلم يعيشون في لندن
احدى المقيمات البريطانيات في لندن هي
التي قامت بهذه المبادره لاضاءه انوار
انوار رمضان طبعا جاء عمده لندن صديق خان
للاشراف على اضاءه هذه الانواع وبالتالي
يعني هذه الانوار يعني تعتبر
ملفته للحديد لانظار العديد من المارين
طبعا
عروب كيف تفاعل مثلا البريطانيون غير
المسلمين او من جنسيات اخرى خصوصا مع موجه
الاسلام وفوبيا ومنها في بريطانيا كمان
اتجاه العرب والمسلمين منهم خصوصا مع هذه
الحملات للتضامن مع المسلمين خلال شهر
رمضان ومن المشاهد اللي عم نشوفها لاول
مره يعني
الحقيقه نادين يعني كنا قد تكلمنا مع عدد
من المارين في بدايه رمضان عندما اضيئت
هذه الانوار بعض الناس لم يعرفون ما يعني
هذه الانوار لماذا اضيئت ولكن رحبوا
بالفكره اعتبروا انها تتماشى مع روح
بريطانيا التي تحاول تعزيز التعدديه
الثقافيه والتعدديه الدينيه في البلاد
ونحن راينا يعني حقيقه العديد من
الفعاليات الخاصه برمضان في لندن هذا
العام سواء من قبل مؤسسات حكوميه كان هناك
ابطال في مقر
وفي الشرطه البريطانيه ايضا ام المؤسسات
غير حكوميه ومنظمات غير ربحيه حتى الدوري
الانجليزي يعني انديه الدوري الانجليزي
نظمت ما بافطار في يعني في انديتها منهم
تشيلسي وحتى ستايديهم وملي الشهير طبعا
نظم مثل نظم افطارا جماعيا وبالتالي هناك
العديد من هذه الفعاليات بالاضافه طبعا
الى يعني كان هناك قرار من انديه الدوري
الانجليزي على وجوب اذا كانت مثلا
المباراه تصادف وقت الافطار وقت اذان
المغرب بانها ستقوم بايقاف المباراه
لاعطاء فرصه للاعبين مثلا
يعني لكسر صيامهم وبالتالي هناك تفاعل
كثير مع اجواء رمضان ولكن كل هذا ياتي تحت
ظل ازمه معيشيه يعني يجب ان نقول ازمه
معيشيه تعيشها تعيشها بريطانيا خاصه غلاء
اسعار الغذاء نحن نعلم بان التضخم وصل الى
اكثر من 10% وتضخم اسعار الغذاء وصل الى
اكبر من 16
على كل هذه المعلومات وانتهى الوقت شكرا
عروس وتضخم طال كل بلدان العالم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات